la parole est à notre collègue cédric
perrin pour le groupe l'est républicain
deux minutes monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues monsieur le premier ministre
henri poupart-lafarge pdg du groupe
alstom a affirmé mardi aux questions à
l'assemblée nationale qu'il ne voyait
pas d'issue structurelles pour le site
de belfort à quelques jours de la
présentation de votre plan de sauvetage
ses propos m'inquiète quelque peu
signifie t'il que vous vous contenterez
de quelques commandes nationales ne
soyons pas dupes c'est une solution à
court terme elle est indispensable pour
charger le site durant les trois années
de baisse de charges mais elle est
insuffisante
c'est d'adaptation structurelle dont a
besoin le site de belfort
alstom doit diversifier son activité et
se positionner sur des marchés à faible
dimension alstom doit charger
prioritairement ses sites français dans
la production des commandes passées à
l'international elle doit faire preuve
de patriotisme industriel
rappelons qu'alstom aperçu plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'euros d' cice et
que dans cice il y a aussi le mot
emplois si le cic donne des droits il
confère aussi quelques devoirs alstom
n'est pas le seul coupable monsieur le
premier ministre l'état à sa
responsabilité
il doit siffler la fin de la récréation
entre la sncf et alstom et cesser de
laisser la sncf mener la politique
ferroviaire de la france vous le savez
la sncf ferme la porte au ferroviaire et
belfort pourrait n'être que la première
manifestation d'une situation qui risque
de s'aggraver
sommes-nous condamnés à être le pays le
plus bête du monde le seul pays dont
certaines entreprises comme la sncf
lancent des appels d'offres favorisant
les entreprises étrangères
si vous souhaitez aider les salariés
monsieur le premier ministre il faut
établir avec alstom et la sncf notamment
une véritable stratégie industrielle à
long terme sauver le site de belfort
s'est sauvé plus de 1200 emplois mais
c'est aussi sauver la capacité française
et vous l'avez du tout à l'heure à
produire des tgv dans le futur
après l annonce brutale de la question
cite alstom à belfort le président la
république vous même monsieur le premier
ministre et vos ministres avaient été
toujours très strict vous avez employé
l'impératif est jamais le conditionnel
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui vous avez une
obligation de résultat quant à elle
aussi en page du site alstom de belfort
merci vous répondent la parole est à mme
anna maxell le maire et pour deux
minutes secrétaire d'état
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur perrin ce gouvernement croit à
l'avenir industriel de la france dans
avenir industriel il y a le mot à venir
et c'est une transition que nous devons
accompagner mais belfort c'est la cité
du lion vous le savez monsieur le
sénateur le lion il s'est re gier
asom est implantée à belfort depuis la
fin du 19e siècle c'est de ce site que
sont sortis les locomotives les motrices
tgv les 480 employés font partie des
neuf mille salariés présents sur les 12
sites les journalistes cynique qui
s'interroge sur le pourquoi tout ce foin
n'ont pas entendu la réponse du
président et du premier ministre je vous
le rappelle ici parce que ce sont 400
femmes et hommes qui ont dédié leur vie
professionnelle à cette entreprise qui
sont concernés et parce que oui ce site
revêt une importance symbolique celle de
la capacité de notre industrie à faire
face à la transition numérique et par
l'innovation de la filière ferroviaire
française nous devons entrer dans
l'économie du 21e siècle alors se pose à
nous deux en jeu le premier qui n'a rien
à voir avec l'actionnariat parce que
nationaliser cette entreprise ne
répondrait pas aux problèmes c'est de
faire face à la baisse de commandes qui
est conjoncturelle nous sortons d'une
période où les commandes et est élevé
pour renouveler l'équipement et les
commandes seront de nouveau élevées à
partir de 2018 2020 lorsque sera
construit le tgv du futur le tj v
4.0 il faut donc assumer ses
responsabilités et faire face à cette
période de transition christophe sirugue
le fait avec le conseiller national de
l'industrie pour définir une feuille de
route stratégique c'est l'avenir du pays
que nous préparons en réorganisant la
filière ferroviaire industriels